[Musique]
anthony à 15 ans élève de 3e c ton
musique qu'il fait ses devoirs et dès
qu'il a terminée il prend la direction
du bureau familiale c'est là qu'il
retrouve ses amis
en quelques clics il peut discuter sur
sa messagerie instantanée je parle avec
mes copains en fait on parlera lors de
nos journées
le petit potin et tout ce qui se passe
de tout et de rien quoi on langage jeune
il va sur msn comme anthony ils sont des
millions d'adolescents à utiliser ce
logiciel édité par microsoft une adresse
électronique et ils peuvent dialoguer
par écrite en temps réel avec une ou
plusieurs personnes de leur choix sans
moyens communication pour parler à tout
le monde peut se voir se parler on que
ces critères sont aidés plein de choses
quoi les musiques des vidéos des choix
en plein de trucs
puis si avantage pas comme le thé phone
un téléphone on paie et puissant paie
pas aujourd'hui en france 8 millions
d'internautes utilisent ce système de
messagerie
les deux tiers ont moins de 17 ans et
messenger a été créé en 1999 tout de
suite il a été sorti dans une vingtaine
de pays dont la france
il a connu un succès très rapide auprès
de la communauté technophiles et puis
ensuite ce sont les jeunes qui se sont
appropriés comme outil de communication
notamment parce que c'est gratuit
gratuit ludique anthony est même équipé
d'une webcam qui lui permet de voir et
d'être vu par ses correspondants
il se rencontrer sur msn on parle dans
la journée les deux choses
et pour ça on écrit comme on parle
oublier l'orthographe sur l'écran de
nouveau code est à nouveau vocabulaire
m'ont écrit phonétiquement ce que c'est
pas pour gagner plus de temps fait 106
dossiers ça dépend et ce pour écrire
plus vite même si je vais à côté de lui
que je veux savoir ce qui correspond
avec sa copine où son papa ben je
comprends rien parce qu'en fait c'est
que que des codes et comprendre à tous
et je pense que c'est pas trop bon aussi
pour au niveau de l'orthographe et de la
grammaire française et tout ça
autre source d'inquiétude le temps passé
sur ces messageries qu'il discute avec
edi ou amélie anthony peut se connecter
sur msn d'une trentaine de minutes à
plusieurs heures
[Musique]